Hey everyone, I'm uh Rahul Dareja from Mortado,
and today we'll be talking about
how to get your AI agents from the promise
that they have to actual real
impact. So today
we'll be covering the fact that AI
is definitely powerful, but there's something
lacking. We'll talk about
how orchestration is that silent force
that really makes your AI agents smart,
and then we'll close out with how Vortado's
point of view, you know, how do we look at how
Vortado can make your AI agents a lot smarter.
So, you know, I bring this up everywhere, right?
You know, you know, AI
has been
the, has been the term,
you know, for the past few years.
Everybody has their own interpretation. Everybody
thinks, you know, you know, AI in very different
ways,
but if you take a closer look, AI
is essentially is this layering
of orchestration with agentic,
right? You have these. Agents that can
really help you perform these front end tasks
really well where they can take
actions for you, you know, they can go
ahead and and write emails for you, but
orchestration gives them that superpower
where they essentially allow you to work on your
enterprise applications they allow you
to perform actions as
creating a new order or, you know, you know, you
know, going ahead and,
you know, adding a new employee to your company.
So, you know, let's talk about.
Where we are in the AI journey right now, right?
So we know that AI is everywhere.
There are, there are companies who have onboarded, uh, AI
agents, you, you see the clouds, the,
the, the bedrocks, the Geminis everywhere,
but what you see is that they're being primarily
used for a lot of front-end
activities, right? People are using their AI agents
to essentially help them write
emails, to help them, you know, find
information, but what they're not really
doing is.
Acting upon your end applications,
the main power or or or the main
data lies in your end applications, the sales
forces, the SAPs, the Zendesk that
you have,
that's where your main data lies, but your AI is
not really able to act upon those applications.
So what's really missing, right? Your, your AI
agents are smart.
You have, they, they have the ability to
perform actions on your behalf,
but why aren't they able to do so?
And the answer to that.
Is
orchestration, right? So if, so
if you
really try to look at any AI agent or
if you really try to look at any enterprise company
who is looking to, you know, adopt AI
agents for them,
4 main things are of prime importance, right?
They essentially want
governed real-time access to their data.
They want process orchestration,
they essentially want a way to
define roles and escalation paths, and
they essentially want a continuous life cycle.
And all of that are the powers that
an orchestration engine can
can bring to you.
Combining AI with orchestration
gives you the combined power where
your AI agents now can essentially
act upon your data.
They can go ahead and interact with your end
applications, perform actions on your behalf.
So if you have to create a new sales order
or onboard a new employee, your
agent is now empowered to do this
with the ability to orchestrate.
Now, why does it matter for agents, right? It's,
you, so orchestration, you know, allows
you to connect your end applications. It
allows
application A to, to speak with Application
B, which essentially is very, very important
for, for agents, right? So if agents have to perform something,
they need to understand
what application do I need to connect to, where
do I extract my data from, where do I
write data to.
You want to implement guardrails, right?
You know, security and trust are
the number one
things that every enterprise looks at, right? They want
to make sure
that if they have an AI agent that they're using to
perform actions, it should be done in
a secure and trustworthy manner.
You should be able to use
all forms of authentication that are available
to essentially interact with and applications,
and your AI agent should comply with those.
This should be enable collaboration right now
the way we look at AI agents is
as an assistant to an employee, you
know, it, you know, it could help a salesperson
bring up deals that that have been dormant
for a long time.
It could help a customer service representative
answer questions in a way which can
solve customer issues a lot quicker.
It can, and your AI agent should be able
to.
Enable collaboration and it should
be able to hand over from a human to
an agent any time
and finally
leave a trace, right? You are having your agent
interact with your end applications
you want to make sure that you're able to leave
that paper trail of what's happening
behind the scenes.
And that's where
Orchestration comes in, right? So orchestration
is your silent force.
It's the force that's gonna enable your agents to
be a lot smarter.
essentially act upon your end applications
and make them more meaningful.
Now, let's try and look at it from a
business process perspective, right?
Every single enterprise customer, right, they
have multiple business processes.
Now, these could be my
order to cash, my
uh procure to pay, or any other
process that I have.
And at the bottom layer is where I have all
of my ends.
This is where
my data resides. These are my systems of
truth of data,
which could be my SAPs, my,
my Salesforce applications, my, or my
other ERPs.
On top of that,
you have your connectivity fabric. This is
how you essentially interact with these
applications.
Now, forward to today.
You already have your agentic layer, you already have
your agents that, that essentially are running,
and you want to,
and you essentially want your agents to perform actions
on your end applications.
What's the missing link?
It's the orchestration layer.
The authorization layer is the one that's going
to allow
interaction of your of your AI
agents with your underlying
applications, which also lets you enable
this deep action layer where your
agents can really perform
actions on your data. They can go
ahead and perform tasks
based on what you're trying to do, right? They can
mimic what's you know what a human can do,
and that's where their, their real power lies, and that's the
power that orchestration brings up.
Now, You know,
a lot of customers have already built
a lot of orchestrations, right? The, the, the whole
idea of orchestration and iPass is not
new, and there are customers who
have, who may have already built
hundreds of thousands of integrations
with AI
in the midst. They don't really want to rebuild
everything, right? They, they, they should be able to reuse what
they've already built, and this is an example
where. An AI app they've onboarded
and can now interact with your with your
pre-built integrations
through MCP, right? And MCP is, you
know, is a great example where it, it
can really enable your AI agents
to become a lot smarter
without having to put a lot of effort because you
already have built your. Registrations you've
made sure that that that
all of your integrations that you have built, they're they're
already using the right
security protocols they're interacting with the right
applications they're using the right accounts and
now you can put your AI agent through MCP
and essentially now
interact with your end applications and perform those
actions.
Now this is where, you know, I'd like to
talk about Vortado's approach, right? You
know, you, you know, with Vortado,
our goal was
to essentially help enable AI
agents to be a lot smarter for them
to go ahead and interact with their with the
end applications and to take actions on your behalf.
Wortado always started off as an.
Torate platform and we use the
power of our Orrate platform to layer
on Agentic on top of it.
With our Agentic platform, it, it uses
the underlying power of Orchestrate to interact
with our end applications and it can
allow you to have your AI agents
now interact with those end applications through
MCP.
And this is where I'd like to introduce to Wortado
one now
if, if you talk to any,
you know.
Any director or any VP
in any enterprise company for them,
these 3 facets are the most important
for their AI adoption journey.
Uh, they want access to the right knowledge,
which means that they want access to their
company documents.
They want, they want
orchestration because they want to make sure that it can
actually perform
actions on a, on a user's behalf,
and the number one thing is trust, right? They want to
make sure that all of this happens in a
layer of governance and in a layer of security.
And these are the three things which we kept in
mind when designing Vortado 1.
So with Vortado 1,
as you can see here, right, with Vortado 1, we,
we started off as an orchestrate
platform, which is, which is our, which
is an iPad iPass Plus, but then we
layered on top
our gentic platform which essentially allows
you to build your own agents or
leverage Vortado's Enterprise MCP
to go ahead and empower your existing agents
to take advantage of your existing, existing
orchestrations.
Now, you might ask me
that, do I need
to have Rotado Orchestrate to use Roortado Agenic?
The answer to that would be no, right? Because you
may have built your orchestrations in
any language, in, in any software,
and you would be able to use Roortado's MCP
to to enable those orchestrations,
you know, to be used with your AI agents
and interact with your end applications.
And that's where,
you know, you know, I add this, another layer
to my diagram earlier,
does does the Enterprise MCP, right? My enterprise MCP
allows my AI agents,
you know, to essentially interact with my end
applications, and now all of
my deterministic.
can now be done in a non-deterministic
way through the use of my AI agents,
and that's where the power of of of MCP
lies and that's where, and that's the power that Rotaro
is essentially
talking about the power of Rotaro's Enterprise
MCP which allows you to interact with these
applications. Now talking about our enterprise
MCP.
With an enterprise MCP, right, the idea was very
simple. The idea was the fact that, you know,
you should be able to
use your existing orchestrate layer.
You already have done a lot, you've already
have done a lot of work in connecting
to your applications, right? You may have the ERPs,
the CRMs
that you've already connected to, and you essentially
are going to use that to empower
your agents. You already have agents
that are performing all of your front-end tasks.
How do you go
from those agents who are just performing
your front-end tasks to actually
go ahead and perform actions on your
applications? And that's where my MCP comes in.
Now, Vortado's Enterprise MCP.
Takes into account,
you know, Vortado's 12,000+
connectors that allow you to interact
with applications. It uses
our preexisting governance model
to ensure that you're able to interact with it and
applications in a secure way.
You're able to essentially impersonate
a user to go ahead and perform an action on your
behalf. So if I am a
support person who wants to go ahead and check,
and check the status of a, of a request,
the action can be performed on my on on my
behalf now,
you know, with, with Rotato's Enterprise MCP.
So essentially,
imagine this, right?
Imagine having your agent, you know,
be it a cloud, be it a chat GPT, be
it, be it Bedrock,
you know, to go ahead and say, summarize my open
sales pipeline.
Uh, it can essentially go ahead and connect to
my Salesforce instances,
look at my John Paul call records,
um, because I already have built those connectors,
capture all of that data, and essentially present
to me one unified view
of, of what my sales pipeline is.
Now, the opportunities with MCP
are endless,
right? You can apply MCP in
multiple different scenarios, right?
You, you, you can take Your existing business
processes,
which, for which you already have the integrations,
expose them via MCP to your, you know,
to your AI agents, and your AI agents
will not, are not gonna help you perform that.
What that does, it really helps
adoption at scale.
Earlier, if you had to perform a business
process, you essentially would have to
go ahead and understand what are your APIs
available, what are your services available, and
then somebody would have to.
Stretch that through
in a very deterministic manner.
Now with MCP
all of that is done through an AI agent.
MCP goes ahead and discovers those APIs, discovers
those applications, and goes ahead and
performs that the action for you. And that's where the
power of MCP lies.
Now, you know, a lot of times I
get asked this question that,
you know, every vendor is talking about
MCP servers, right? We have,
you know, uh, a lot of CRM
applications, ERP applications who essentially
have their own MCP servers.
You know, why,
why would you essentially choose
Vertado's Enterprise MCP over these vendor-specific
MCP servers?
Number one, right? It, it all goes back
to the whole idea of tool proliferation,
right? Back in the days,
uh, you know, when this whole idea
of
orchestration started, right, every single company
had their own tool, right? SAP had their own
integration tool, um, Oracle
had their own. Tool and all of
these tools required you to have
still, you, you know, uh,
a separate you know level of skill for
each tool. It also required you to have
separate governance models and essentially
you, you need to have a separate set of people
who essentially were, were going ahead and managing
these tools
now. What that does, it
now with with MCP as well, it's the same
thing, right? Every vendor is gonna have its own MCP tool
which is, which is gonna have its own security
model, it's, its own dominance model, which
gets us to the same point which we were
about 20 years ago.
You know, we, we get to a point where there's
again tool proliferation in the states, it's
MCP proliferation.
Which makes, which makes your life even harder,
but with something like Vertado's Enterprise MCP
where you can essentially interact with
all of the applications that you have
through a single unified layer, it
allows you to accelerate your value because
you're essentially building out an MCP
server which is exposed to your agents,
which follows a security protocol that you
have built out. You do not really need to
rely on the security protocols that you
have from your
vendor specific MCPs.
And it essentially is powered by
by Vortara One, right? You know, our entire
Connectivity landscape really helps you empower
your entire MCP MCP adoption,
and that's where I say that.
You know, without an enterprise
MCP you're not orchestrating,
you're actually outsourcing control to
every vendor in your stack
because you essentially are at the mercy of
every vendor that you, that has their own MCP
server
to adapt to their,
uh, to, to adapt to their standards and adapt
to their guidelines. And that's where Rotado's
Enterprise MCP
becomes very, very important.
Finally, right, um,
you know, we, we, we talk a lot about
MCP,
but one thing that's core to MCP
and to AI
and for AI to be smarter,
is
the orchestration layer. The orchestration
layer
needs to be powerful, needs to be adaptable,
which in a sense, allows you to go
ahead and build your integrations in a manner
which are secure,
governed, and scalable.
And that's where Vortado's enterprise
grade abilities come out of the box, right? You are
able to essentially have,
you know, a completely managed offering.
You are essentially able to, to, to deploy
your applications in an always on model.
We provide to you zero downtime
upgrades. We provide to you log and audit streaming,
but at the same time,
there are, you can, you can have your orchestrations
that can listen to your
applications in multiple ways, right? I can listen to a
change.
In an object inside of Salesforce, I can listen
to a new
file added to an S3 bucket, and all of
that can be done through Vortato.
So, essentially, the idea is that, you know,
In this agenda journey.
Because, you know, you know, AI agents are the future,
but orchestration still remains true.
You need to, you know, partner with a platform that
can really help to make your orchestrations
faster, secure, and more enterprise grade,
and that's where Vortado comes in.
And finally,
you know,
I would, I would, you know, recommend all of you to come
by our booth, booth 1085. We have multiple
live demonstrations, um, available
that will help you, that will help us showcase our
orchestrated energetic platform, show you the
power of Vortaro's Enterprise MCP, and
essentially give you a flavor of
what Vortado can do for your business.
Thank you.